37 sur quatre secondes les intermittents
du spectacle coûte il trop cher à
l'assurance chômage
la question est au coeur des discussions
entre patronat et syndicats et cela
depuis plusieurs décennies
on dit qu'un quart des allocations
chômage est absorbée par les comédiens
les chanteurs qui sont souvent et
longtemps son travail du fait du
caractère discontinue de leur activité
professionnelle les artistes ou les
techniciens de du visuel bénéficie
depuis 1936 d'un régime spécifique
d'indemnisation chômage
lorsqu'il s'agit de faire des économies
leur statut est régulièrement remise en
cause en 1991 par exemple le patronat
accusé les intermittents d'être
responsable d'un quart du déficit de
l'unedic
c'est un mensonge nous défions monsieur
giral et nous sommes pas un débat public
sur cette question
nous allons démontrer dès ce soir tous
les chiffres de monsieur giral qui ont
été repris par martine aubry s'en faut
les années passent et les intermittents
sont toujours dans le collimateur du
patronat d'autant plus que leur nombre
ne cesse de croître
quarante et un mille en 1991 contre 2
172 milles en 2017 et le déficit de
l'assurance chômage continue de se
creuser en 2003 de nouvelles discussions
entre les partenaires sociaux conclut à
une réforme du régime spécifique des
intermittents c'est très fort et
d'indispensables parce que ce système
est infiniment goûteux et
scandaleusement gérer n'oubliez pas les
intermittents du spectacle sont payés
par le fric des travailleurs du privé
dorénavant pour toucher le chômage un
intermittent devra effectuer 100 107
heures de travail en 10 mois au lieu de
douze des modifications qui passe mal
auprès des artistes et des techniciens
la mobilisation nationale est sans
précédent et plusieurs festivals sont
annulés cet été-là dont celui d'avignon
les intermittents envahissent même les
plateaux télé nous voulons une véritable
réforme négociée avec l'ensemble des
concernés
nous voulons que nos propositions soient
prises en compte
nous demandons une émission de débat
contradictoire à une heure de grande
écoute sur ces questions ce que nous
défendons nous le défendons pour tous et
11 ans plus tard le patronat est encore
plus catégorique
les propositions du medef pour réformer
l'assurance chômage sont jugés explosive
premières préconisations mettre fin au
régime spécial des intermittents du
spectacle le but les réintégrer au
régime général
aujourd'hui les discussions entre
partenaires sociaux pour réformer
l'assurance chômage sont de nouveau
ouvertes
le mot d'ordre faire des économies les
intermittents seront ils une nouvelle
fois dans le viseur du patronat
[Musique]